next game starting soon playing some guy
named Daniel
nitzki think I've heard of him
before what are we expecting
D4 I know yeah DA's C oh DA's capable of
playing jobava
London have I played my new idea against
against
him this we're going to find out
shortly if he's prepared for
this I do have his jobava London course
I don't think he mentions this move so
uh I think we're in at least new
territory for
him I haven't reviewed this line in a
[Music]
while I remember the plan is to
eventually play F5
F4 I also remember that we can throw an
A5 like provoke A3 and
[Music]
then later do
things yeah the plan is to play F5 next
move
G4 we'll start with
A5 I I analyzed this line with engine G4
never came up uh according to stockfish
but I'm on my
own probably Bishop
Bishop
G5 cuz now with inclusion of A5 A3 Queen
D2 I take and then there's a
pin always have to watch after Queen D6
but okay Knight Rook uh rook's defended
by the
Knight
interesting so if I take Rook
[Music]
G1 there's also
E3 E3 might be the
best it's the
simplest because this way I get a queen
trade where the Rooks don't get
connected if I took took then rook's
defended but in this case after take
take take
take um the king's still on
[Music]
E1 and C5 and A3 both
attacked doing well on
[Music]
time that's a good move it's
counterattacking I can take
yeah he's so tricky in these situations
so I'll still have to work for
it and simple move
develop Bishop
B5 let's just
improve so up
[Music]
pon and take
First
Rook A5 may be
[Music]
coming let's watch Daniel nitzki who is
playing against I am Rosen and I am
Rosen is actually doing well against
Daniel there's B5
here will he play B5 is a big
question and threat is this in this goes
Knight C5 a move that I also like um
Rook A2
Daniel could still win this game I think
very likely it's going to be a draw if
Eric if Eric plays precisely like maybe
H5 on the king up there's always B5 if
he wants to draw as
well yeah he does play H5 so
taking is in a lot of trouble here cuz
the Rook is behind the pass Pawn lot of
trouble very very bad
position so we got the trade Knight E4
King C2 probably Knight F6 I guess it's
also Knight F2 and A2
maybe playing safe
back just Knight G4 Knight H6 should be
winning as well this Brook H2 is almost
checkmates not Knight E3 cuz then
there's Rook H2 plays G5 another good
move from E3 would Eric by the way doing
very very well um just King G7 maybe
Knight E3 also just good yeah just
Knight E3 Eric's going to win this game
most likely King
G7 okay G4 G3 is good knight C4 is good
E4 is good literally all moves lead to
Rome for um all moves lead to roome here
for uh uh for Eric King G6 large number
just I don't know G4
maybe Rook B5 Rook B2 also pretty good
too yeah now probably just Rook B5 Rook
B2
witty alien is is incoming I don't know
what you mean by that Rook B5 is pretty
straightforward here plays B5 which is
still good enough King F7 of course
Eric's got to move a little bit quicker
though Eric's a little bit too slow here
King
F5 I mean I guess takes are still B4 B4
of
course why is Eric so
slow yeah now probably Rook D5 or Rook
A6 I mean everything's just good enough
Knight E3 Knight d B6 Rook
B7
Eric
G3 ah and he he tricked him with Knight
E4 nice move from Eric yeah now now of
course it's Knight
F6 Dan is going to hang The Rook on
purpose wow big win from Eric Rosen very
very impressive Eric continuing on his
success in Doha kind sad I didn't second
out of
two I think that was a nice game overall
like I got the the opening prep which
worked out
beautifully like the prospect of F5 F4
and then it provoked G4 which I think
was a little bit too much for
white okay yeah heart rate over
150 have to stay
calm thanks everyone for the energy I
mean da beats me like probably 98% of
the time
so we can see oh maybe yeah maybe only
like 90% of the time or
85 but not too often I can get a win
against
him and he's so resourceful too like
even I mean against most players it
should be like pretty routine win but
took a lot of work
and it's like if I take the pawn white
just
wins I I was aware of this um this
mating idea it's so crazy to think white
could generate a m threat with uh Rook
on A2 Knight on
[Music]
E7 oh hikaro commentated the whole end
game oh that's cool someone should clip
it